Wahlabend in Köln da mache ich mich
natürlich schick ganz traditionell schön
rasieren oh Haare abflämmen
Nasenhaare ziehen
und augenbrauen wachsen
ja ich glaube das würde Erdogan gut
gefallen oder oder es ist zu Anbietern
dann ab auf die kolbstraße die
deutsch-türkische Straße in Köln aber
ihr könnt ja auch ein bisschen mehr
Party sein jetzt fahre ich ja vielleicht
nächste Woche in die Türkei tatsächlich
und eventuell Interview ich auch Erdogan
haben Sie irgendwelche Tipps wie ich das
angehen kann was sollte ich sagen was
sollte ich besser nicht sagen
nicht in die Augen schauen oh echt ja
das lieber Raubtieren eigentlich ne
genau okay
Google
nein nein nein nein die Frage ist ja
folgende ich also ich darf in die Türkei
was sollte ich beachten wenn ich ein
Interview mit Erdogan führe
gar nichts ganz normal nicht was
genommen das ZDF schickt mich nächste
Woche in die Türkei
ein bisschen aufpassen ich gebe ihn
jetzt diese Tröte
und sie Tröten immer wenn ich ein Thema
sage dass ich besser nicht ansprechen
sollte bei Erdogan ja okay wir gehen mal
durch sie Tröten bei brenzligen Themen
alles klar
sonnenblue
die muss man so vorsichtig sein ja ich
habe vielleicht die Chancen nächste
Woche in die Türkei zu reisen und
vielleicht ein Interview mit Erdogan zu
führen
viel Spaß Katzenbabys
Pressefreiheit
ich gebe ihnen 20er wenn sie nicht
Erdogan wählen also 20 Lira 20.000
gegeben
große teure Paläste
wenn du hier ist ja immer noch nichts
los na dann habe ich ja noch Zeit für
eine Expertin wie kann es sein dass man
jahrelang und demokratische Standards
abbaut und dann doch in eine Stichwahl
muss wer hat da versagt
insbesondere wenn man auch die
Möglichkeit hatte das ganze Wahlsystem
so zu verändern dass man am Ende auf
jeden Fall gewinnt
da ist auch schon mal sehr viel schief
gelaufen sie können jede Themen was Sie
wollen können Sie ihn fragen und ich
komme sicher wieder raus auf jeden Fall
können wir holen mich zur Not raus
100.000%
Mann ist keine Sorgen alles klar auch
okay top das Auto noch davor bitte genau
das Auto davor dass wir Jubelbilder
haben Leute wir müssen das ein bisschen
inszenieren dass es Fernsehen wenn ihr
nichts los ist ich gebe ein Zeichen und
dann geht hier die Post ab ja ich gebe
ein Zeichen und dann richtig Gas geben
okay und los
Leute hier seine Wahnsinnsstimmung ein
Auto jagt das andere
Wahnsinn was hier los ist ich kann euch
sagen irre da hinten schon wieder ganz
viele die sind jetzt nicht im Bild aber
überall ist ja also Wahnsinn damit
zurück ins Studio irre was hier los ist
hallo Youtube unten könnt ihr den Kanal
abonnieren er deutet nach unten in die
Infobox neben mir gibt es weitere
interessante Videos Verlinkungen Komma
vielen Dank
[Musik]